hey let's go impress my name is Philippa
welcome to part two of undertale it's
been a [ __ ] more than a week I don't
know how I'm so busy I don't even have
time to play a game
hi we wanted to play this for so a week
well so much cuz it's lovely this game
is lovely so there we go let's just get
right into it I have one hour to spare
[ __ ] hell people don't realize all
right use the box absolutely
okay so I can store items in it uh let's
just take the tough Club and then we'll
use that in the future and a fishing run
yes yes yes it's a photo of a
weird-looking monster
call me here's my number you decide not
to call awesome glad we did that
let's keep moving oh it's these guys so
as I was saying about Undine Undine I
don't know if it's alright oh [ __ ] he
saw us are they gonna explode what Sam's
oh my god is sad a human uh actually I
think that the rock
ah hey what's madam oh my god what's
that in front of the rock oh my god I
shot a human
yes oh my god since I finally did it and
dying will oh yeah I'm done is a bad
kick guy
I forgot see it's been a long time I'm
gonna I'll be so popular popular popular
and humid you shall not pass this area
hi the great pepper s will subdue I will
then I will then capture you you will be
delivered to the capital then then I'm
not sure what's next
in any case continue only if you're
damned yeah I'm surprised you didn't
just take us in right away well that
went well don't sweat it kid I'll keep
an eye socket out for you
I suck it brilliant ah let's do a quick
save cuz I don't [ __ ] up I realize diet
I woke up with a cold today so if me
doing voices it's gonna be a problem
further along I'll stop alright I don't
want oh God
oh yeah there's battles in [ __ ] let's
flee uh I guess this is one of them the
bad parts about me doing the series all
at once I'll probably live stream some
episodes so that I don't miss out on
like essential gameplay sup uh I don't
know I meant it for the story I'm not in
it for their RPG gameplay elements there
are some narration in the Carver box
observe the well-crafted send physician
who could have built this pump I bet it
was very okay we don't need to look at
that what the [ __ ] is this
did something move was it my imagination
I can only see moving things if
something was moving for example a human
I'll make sure it never moves again Oh
what do we do then
pet him he's too suspicious of my
movement don't move an inch all right
I'm not moving okay
I can't seem to find anything what if
you check in easily excited by movement
hobbies include squirrels just like me
Wow will it move this time
you can't seem to find anything what if
we spare will it move this time I don't
know what I'm doing to be hundred
percent honest okay what if we attack
him
okay we're supposed to attack it I don't
want to kill him that
see I don't know if he seems like a main
character let's cut him
Oh hahaha water I'm Ben pack
pot Pat broadband fit right dogger has
been pet you pet dog Oh where's that
coming from
but it's so weird
there's no into it bad pit let's keep
adding that bench well this is thorough
I think I don't know English okay that's
enough
what I thought he liked it
better MA never never stop petting Baga
never maybe we can do something else now
oh we can spare him now okay cool
something Pat me something that is a
movie I'm gonna go I'm gonna need some
dog treats for this Oh
Oh oops I should not have done that
hello sending money there no well then
someone's been smoking dog treats how do
you do that oh this is coming we're sons
okay there hey here's something
important to remember my brother has a
very special attack if you see a blue
attack don't move any won't hurt you
here's an easy way to keep in mind
imagine a sub-site when you see a stop
sign you stop right
sometimes are red so imagine blue steps
okay [ __ ] it simple right when fighting
think about blue something
why couldn't I
why can't you just made it blue red I
mean North ice south as West ice is
snowed in tail and ice
well then Easter this [ __ ] you're so
lazy you were napping all night how did
they get there I think that's called
sleeping excuses excuses
aha the human arrives in order to stop
you my brother and I have created some
puzzle I think you will find this one
quite shocking for you see this is the
invisible electricity base when you
touch the walls of this maze this OP
will administer a heart attack sound
like fun because the amount of fun you
would probably have
it's actually rather small I think okay
you're crying what sense
what did you doubt I think the human has
to hold the orb oh okay
so now we know how to walk that's
brilliant
hold this please this gave me so silly
like I can't remember a game this silly
well that I think I did it
incredible you slippery snail you solved
it so easily too easily
however the next bother with Madonna is
amazing and it's designed by my brother
sons you will surely be confound it I
know I am hey hurry moonwalked away
let's talk to sons hey thanks my brother
seems like he's having fun by the way
did you see and I we're not Phineas way
we made that a few weeks ago for our
custom pony yes I want anything else
since keeps calling it his battle potty
man it's my brother call Oh
what that [ __ ] who the poor you I don't
understand why these aren't selling it's
the perfect weather for something cold
Oh a customer hello would you like some
nice cream that's brilliant
it's frozen treat that warms your heart
not just 15
all right [ __ ] here you go have a
super-duper day you got the knife school
I love nice screen what we got here what
what is going on here I gotta play with
you oh my god is this very frustrating
Oh God
come on buddy come on come on buddy come
on hey Ike out yeah slot done
ibrahimovic commie Oh God
Oh God boom [ __ ] this might be tricky
boom mail that let's get the ball in the
hole oh no it's shrinking now let golf
let it what's that [ __ ] it well then
I'm gonna talk to science now I've been
thinking about selling treats to won
some fried snow it's just 5g ah [ __ ]
did I say 5g I'm in 58 no they're right
that's still too low
oh my god
hiss got against hearse
alright I'm a little confused
and gets up moving the mic a little
[ __ ] you're not the star of this show
I'm gonna get a [ __ ] something else
started enough that it's [ __ ]
pop-filter in my mouth I'm not trying to
eat the pop filter I promise it just
needs to be there can we go here human
up y'all ready for sans where's the
puzzle it's right there on the ground
trust me there's no way they can get
past this one monster kids words search
hey kids can you help me solve this
puzzle fall winter spring summer monster
skeletons mermaid robot cigars yes yes
Fleur Fleur broiler and hot well I see
chaos blabla flavor and I don't see I
see monster what's the point
am I missing something here
Oh sans that didn't do anything
whoops I know I should have used today's
crossword instead what cause would I
can't believe you said that
in my opinion junior jumble is easily
the hardest what really do that's
easy-peasy word Scrabble
that's for baby pants unbelievable
humans solve this dispute which is
harder jumble across me well I don't
[ __ ] know I I never done a jumble
it's that bad we don't have them
crossword
you two are weird crosswords are so easy
it's the same solution every time I just
fill all the boxes in with the letters
said because every time I look at a
crossword all I can do is awesome uh
[ __ ] my camera's running out of battery
all I can do is snow yeah oh man I love
this game so far a Paris finds
difficulty in interesting places
yesterday he got stumped trying to solve
the horoscope but horoscopes doesn't
have solutions I better be going by
better by by better better better better
better never ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever knowing the miles might
one day find a way to heat up the
spaghetti it fills you with
determination [ __ ] yeah it does it's a
plate of frozen spaghetti it's so cold
it's stuck to the table but here's a
microwave but it's unplugged all the
same all of this thing's sink spaghetti
it's a note from papyrus here man please
enjoy the spaghetti little do you know
this spaghetti is a trap the side to
entice you you'll be so busy eating it
that you won't realize that you are
progressing surly cheap Dickens by the
great papyrus mere purpose
hahahahaha alright well then I will not
try and solve this spaghetti puzzle and
move on warning dog marriage I did not
expect the sign to say that I'm not
gonna lie it I probably would have
guessed probably anything but dog
spaghetti maybe lesser dog appears what
am I looking at right now am I looking
at it a lesser dog a friend let's let's
not [ __ ] with a lesser dog I um very
interesting game what is this wow
oh it's just a map in it it will show
where I find something ok so it's a map
of this area I assume and it's right
between the holes got it don't worry
about it makes sense in my brain here no
I got that wrong
here here [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
that's what are the black things are
they trees no yeah yeah the black things
are trees so it's between the trees god
no you guys are super cute but I'm gonna
go alright this guy Oh toby fox needs to
like make the new selection of pokemon
cuz like there it is there's a switch
hidden in the clock like switch is stuck
man what i do so he needs to come up
with like that next 250 pokemon there we
go it's all the creatures oh god are so
weird
where's that Snoopy deaf Snoopy ok so if
I don't move I'll be okay if you're a
smell identify your smell the puns the
puns are out of control man
um here's a weird smell it makes me want
to eliminate eliminate eat oh no dog are
they kissing that's so cute
I'm just not gonna move
the dogs are saying sickly-sweet things
to each other dog a me and dog Arisa
roll around your roll you roll around in
the dirt and snow you smell like a weird
puppy take my wife's please don't
actually oh that won't hit me that's not
good
the dogs may want to read smelly what if
I sniff them the dogs sniff you again
after rolling in the dirt your smell all
right
what smells like a are you actually a
little puppy okay so I just need to
survive got it ah the dogs think that
you may be a lost puppy
alright so let's keep rolling around you
smell like a weird puppy okay how do I -
this in the best way possible
why not sucking okay got it that I just
died I just died and congrats to me
Wow pet buy another pup I'm so confused
okay uh I think I may be a lost puppy
let's pet her as well what about me
a dog that pets dogs amazing that is
amazing as a powers and I'm so confused
the dogs mine have been expanded and now
we can spare them you won I'm starting
to slowly understand the gameplay of
this game so you can choose to fight
them or you can choose to act all right
I know
Brainiac right ah dogs can pet other
dogs a new world has opened up for us
thanks we had puppy it's not right Edgar
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right let's go self another puzzle
can't wait turn on every X into unser
with an L 0 or is an O an O then press
the switch
I don't think matters turn every X and 2
at 0 and then hit the switch
how will I do that Oh what okay I got it
um nailing it so smart
smartest [ __ ] Lam alright now we
hit the switch
boom [ __ ] what how did you vote on the
trip and more importantly is there any
left for me the spaghetti if you talking
about spaghetti and oh I ate it really
wowie
no one's ever enjoyed my cooking before
I wonder why I really do
well then Fred non-human I MasterChef
but Faris will make you all the path
that you could ever won
why did he say that so viciously I don't
know my brother stared started a sock
collection recently house a turning
sometimes I wonder what he would do
without such a cool guy taking care of
him yeah he is pretty cool I'm not gonna
lie he's very [ __ ] cool I wish I had a
sock collection human how do I say this
you were taking a long time to arrive so
I decided to improve this puzzle by
arranging the snow to look more like my
face unfortunately the snow froze to the
ground now the solution is different and
as usual my lazy brothers nobody around
I suppose what I'm saying is worried not
human I the great papyrus will solve
this conundrum then we can both busy
meanwhile feel free to try the position
I'll try not to give away the answer
turn every X into 0
then press the switch the puzzles are
getting harder hard is he following me
nailed it
boom Wow
you solved it and you did it all without
my help incredible I'm impressed you
must care about puzzles like I do Wow
I'm sure you'll love the next puzzle
then I'm sure I will the puzzles are fun
it might even be too easy for you
yeah ha ha ha ha ha all the characters
so good good job on solving it so
quickly you didn't even need my help
which is great cuz I love doing
absolutely nothing hashtag relatable
alright let's get go what do I get this
sorry just need a breather I have a cold
hey it's the human you're gonna love the
puzzle it was made by the great doctor
Elvis oh I can't wait to meet him
you see these files sorry child once I
throw this switch they will begin to
change color each color has a different
function red tails are impassable you
can al-bakr them yellow times are
electric
they will electric eight green tiles are
alarm channels if you step on them you
will have to find a month orange tiles
are orange scented and you will smell
delicious blue tiles are watching the
house swim through it if you like but if
you smell like oranges the piranhas are
watching also if a blue tile is next to
a yellow tile the water will also SAP
you wait papa tiles are slippery you
will slide to nexor however the slippery
soap smells like lemons which piranhas
do not like purple and blue are okay
finally pink tiles they don't do
anything step on them all you like how
was that understand understand
exhalation ah yeah sure great then
that's what I think this parcel is
entirely random when I pull the switch
it will make a puzzle that has never
been seen before not even I will know
the solution I swear to God if it's not
a puzzle
just a moon walk away just moon just
spin away actually let's forget it from
earlier it wasn't too bad for Bryan
brother since he started cooking lessons
it's been improving a lot I bet if he
keeps it up next year Lee will even make
something edible the machine isn't
working well I'm glad we went through
all that [ __ ] it's that dog stuck it's
like in a piece of ice
I'm gonna save first knowing that dog
will never give up trying to make the
perfect snow dog it feels even
termination I am so filled with
determination
this dog is staring blankly it is not
waiting for it to turn into art
Oh
what okay let's talk to this couch thing
a dark considers itself an artist but
doesn't ever know what to create it
probably doesn't help that it's brain
it's the size of a piece of kibble 100%
Oh another psycho puzzle I just walk
right into it
[ __ ] I'll reset it just in case I I
don't know I just die it's a snow
perverse and here's sense it's a lump of
snow with a word sense right not it okay
um all right so let's think about this
okay I think I got it boom and we did it
good job everyone especially me
since I did all the work you shouldn't
feel too bad you've been sitting through
15 minutes unless I cut something that
actually it's probably more like 30
okay what's up that's it
all right what's going on here that is
again are you lost
no cannot oh wow
yes they have seen one of those before
is that a dog coming out of there you
know what I'm just gonna go all right oh
this is nice this is lovely who lives
here it's a door yeah I can uh-huh I
love this sound let's deactivate all the
mushrooms and learn nothing from the
experience all right let's go back cuz I
don't know what else to do
I wonder I want to see like cosplay for
this person like really good one that'd
be cool I've been like that big get out
a good costume Halloween costume all
right let's go this way then right
here's something else it's a snow proof
and this is a snow this however is a
snow proof surprisingly it's a snow
proof what are tiny dog has woof
the sign said wolf awesome
there you are thank you for that random
person that I don't know who you are on
seem sorry I met a new computer that a
didn't forgot to turn off those well
you're not that tiny
oh man
what is his song it's the greater dog I
like out of this tiny little dog face is
unlike that spear and the glove and okay
well let's see what we can do with
greater die I think we can play with him
it's not excited enough to play with all
right Oh God it's watching me intently
alright let's what is back in me let's
try that you call the greater dog it
bounds toward you flaking slobbering
into your face greater dog is seeking
affection let's pet him then he curls up
in your lap as it is pet by you
it gets so comfortable it falls asleep
then it wakes up it's so excited what
deaf greater dog is padding the ground
with head front paws so now we play with
it you make a snowball and throw it for
the dog to fetch it splits on the ground
great a dog picks up all the snow in the
area and brings it to you now dog is
very tired arrest his head on you
gotta make sure that I die now that'd be
[ __ ] bummer
great a dog wants some TLC so I'm slowly
starting to understand this game so you
can either play with fight or Act and I
think that's really cool because that
immediately makes me want to replay the
game by doing that not that I want to
kill people it's just that I want to I
just like when there's two different
choices in a game and you can play them
very differently fire truck is like an
example of where you can either save or
kill and I love that game and I love
replaying it so I think that's awesome
uh anyway uh where was I okay so we
played with it I would pet the dog how
about we ignore the dog okay what is he
doing it's like Edgar if you ignore him
he just goes [ __ ] insane let's ignore
some more I'm scared
what's TLC is that like some American
brand food okay so when it's blue no
damn it I [ __ ] that
shame on me
we'll keep going no right I'm trying to
stay determine game shut up
yay okay I did it
that was hard oh man I gotta say I
really love playing this game and I
really enjoy just doing regular
playthroughs like personally okay I'll
get to it after this all right
human this is your final and most
dangerous challenge behold a gauntlet of
deadly terror
oh boy that actually looks dangerous
when I say the word it well fully
activate cannons will fire spiteful
swing blades with [ __ ] each pot will
swing violently up and down only the
tiniest chance of victory will remain
are you ready
because I am about to do it
not the dog anything but the dog well
what's the hold up hold up what hold up
um I'm about yakavetta now but uh does
it look very activated
well this challenge it seems maybe too
easy to defeat the human with yeah we
can't use this one I am a skeleton with
seven my puzzles are very fair and my
chapter expertly cook but there's Smith
that is too direct
no class at all i way it goes he's
actually a sweetheart whoo
what're you got this is another decisive
victory for Paris yeah ha ha really been
doing it doing I played through again
it's been so long
this is that I don't want to do daily
uploads if it's not a game that I know
will do well on the channel uh because I
feel like I'm spamming then so I'd
rather just do it all in one bulk and
that way I think it will work
alright I'm sorry I got a place myself
but I also gotta please you bros that
sounds like a weird sense it might be
hard to understand but it's how I want
to do it so I think the next thing we'll
do actually there's so much that's not
another game that I really been want to
play I just want to say I'm sorry I've
been neglecting playthroughs they are
coming back I don't uh
cuz there's also like you want series to
do well and all that stuff and I feel
that's like there's a lot of pressure
for them to do that if I upload every
single day and uh this way I can just do
it and just literally just focus on the
game and nothing else like it don't
matter anything else uh okay I don't
know what my brother's going to do now
if I were you I would make sure I
understand blue attacks bro I understand
blue attacks well more than you ll ever
that's a welcome to Snowden well this is
cute the side of a such a friendly town
filthy with determination indeed hello
traveler how can I help you
should we sell some stuff sell something
does this look like a pawn shop I don't
know how it works where you come from
but if I started spending money on old
branches and use Pantages I'd be out of
business in a jiffy it's so true I don't
know why I like every RPG ever you can
just dump all your crap on it or like
random merchants all right what do you
sell then what's a pistol a manly
bandana it has ABS on it
well I clearly need that ah that might
begin uh let's tell us about your life
life it's the same as usual a little
claustrophobic but all we all know deep
down the freedom is coming away as long
as we got that hope we can grit our
teeth and face the same struggles day
after day all right I don't care about
your life Jesus Christ
let's check in
I'm sorry by my cold it probably sounds
disgusting I I do apologize right I'm
not gonna spend money on the end
I love the doormat I want that doormat
I'm not kidding um oh boy
that took us very far how big is this
town this hodge I wish I played this
during Christmas this is so cozy that
lady over there something about her
deserves me same it's in my little
cinnamon just the cutest burn bans are
so adorable teehee it's Marcia awful
Chiefs tormented a local monster by
decorating its tree like horns so we
started giving that monster presents to
make it feel better now it's a tradition
to put presents underneath a decorated
tree oh well that makes sense
yo you're a kid too right yes
can't tell kiss you're wearing a
scripture awesome this town doesn't have
a mayor but if there's ever a problem a
skeleton will tell a fish lady about it
that's politics uh-huh all right you
guys look like trigger treaters everyone
is always laughing and cracking jokes
trying to forget our modern crisises
dreariness crowding Michael sunlight I
will join them but I'm just not very
funny well then we all know the
Underground has problems but we smile
anyway why we can't do anything so why
be more rows about it library this is
too much conversation here wait the sign
was misspelled library I wanted hard to
say like you double-checked or something
that'd be funny that looking you're
right you're someone that has trouble
doing crosswords aren't you [ __ ] you all
right [ __ ] you I don't need you [ __ ] you
at the mailbox thank you it's prepare us
oh okay this is where they live so
locked what do we got over here then
instead of floating ice block oh boy
it's cold oh boy that's cold if we just
freeze to ice if we just [ __ ]
solidify here oh man allow me to tell
you about some complex feeling feelings
like the joy of finding another pasta
lover that's so cute
the admiration for another puzzle
another's puzzle solving skills the
desire to have a cool smart person think
you are cool these feelings they must be
what you are feeling right now I can
only imagine what it must be like to
feel that way after all I am very great
I don't ever wonder what having lots of
friends is like I picked a your lonely
human worry knocked out she'll be lonely
no longer either great prepares will be
yours no no this is all wrong I can't be
your friend you're a human I must
capture
then I can fulfill my lifelong dream
before popular prestigious that's for
Paris the newest member of the Royal
Guard
oh no refining him a mnemonic um well
then it should be pretty sad add insult
or flurry let's start by checking it he
likes to say in your hand
well oh you did it is that it shut it
alright let's flirt with him
watch flatten so you're a finer reveal
your ultimate feeling well I'm a
skeleton we're very high standard I can
make spaghetti oh no you're meeting all
my standards my gosh it means I have to
go on a date with you let's state later
after I catch a if that only does if
that is attack the furs is thinking
about what to wear every let's flirt
with him some more no can't we can't do
that how selfless you want me to feel
better by fighting him I don't deserve
such hospitality from you is it getting
harder Adam
he dabs some bone cologne behind his ear
let's keep flirting with him you flirt
but to no avail
seems act won't escalate this battle
let's state later after I caption am I
missing something maybe I'm not sure
is there an item I need for this battle
oh my god I'm so sorry I'll turn it up
for next one um it seems like the game
is literally telling me that that won't
work what if I get hit he won't actually
kill me I feel like could that be the
key that seems dumb enough that actually
might work you know I'm saying
cuz I don't see how anyone can die oh
okay
you're too weak I was easily able to
capture you I will now send your data
capture some are as sense calls it our
garage you're in the doghouse now yeah
[ __ ] was that sound
oh well then okay it looks like we did
it
interesting it's a note from prepares
sorry I have to lock you in the guest
room until i'm dinah right there for you
to make a setup refreshments and our
combinations have been provided
yeah yeah fully Yosh papyrus I love him
I really want to date him so bad
sorry ma yeah it's just dry food we're
into me like a dog
well I do smell like one can i smoke it
oh well then let's check out their house
actually let's go back into the same
dead dead dead dead better that did that
did it did
all right sorry I had so many thoughts I
don't know how to say them but um let's
just keep playing it's locked
oh it's locked - what if we trying to
escape again um alright we'll see what
happens hopefully we won't have to go
through all that again
oh right Carter down here man I've gone
wait it's right in front of me
hello I was worried that you had gotten
lost I gotta say like it's told me
really understands how the player thinks
which is something that may seem pretty
easy but I it's not like I know game
development to understand how people
react and what they will do in certain
situations to kind of guide them through
it it's really not that it's it seems
like he understands and that's really
cool cuz like I haven't gotten stuck
once in the game and it really it played
someone like it plays itself but I still
feel like I'm in control and that's
that's a compliment I guess it didn't
sound like one I'll just stop wait a
second you're not supposed to escape get
back that
getting intense alright let's act but
with him some more you do receive
fighting to play back let's say later
okay
okay so now it well it's his happy
wheels I'm cold
um insult
let's keep flirting with him then we Oh
God
nailed it
oh my god ah [ __ ] marina sauce I don't
think that works
Oh God
snuck up on me MTT brand fishy cream
I had my favourite ah I might actually
die
what is he saying
oh [ __ ] I'm very confused right now
not gonna lie okay so we left again
let's do another safe dead dead dead
dead dead dead dead then um okay let's
try to escape again but I'm getting
really hungry actually I think I need to
end this episode here I'll see you the
next one thank you for watching i I
really hope you're enjoying it
maybe you've probably seen the game
before and I understand maybe it's not
the most interesting game because
everyone's already played it but I
really appreciated you being here I'm
enjoying it and yeah it's cool I'm glad
you're here that's it for now I'll see
you in part 3 as always stay awesome
press